Partystimmung – aber nicht
in einem Club, sondern in einem Zug:
Die Fahrt mit dem Kulturzug Berlin-Breslau
ist eine Reise der besonderen Art.
Nur am Wochenende gibt es diese direkte
Verbindung zwischen den beiden Städten.
19 Euro kostet eine Fahrt.
In viereinhalb Stunden kommen die
Fahrgäste nicht nur dem Zielort näher.
Sie können auch eine Menge über die
deutsch-polnische Vergangenheit erfahren.
Eine der Organisatorinnen
ist Natalie Wasserman.
Der Berlinerin mit polnischen Eltern
ist der Austausch beider Länder wichtig.
Also, der Kulturzug
bietet einfach wunderbare Anlässe,
tatsächlich miteinander
ins Gespräch zu kommen –
und zwar nicht nur
hautnah mit den Künstlern, ja,
sondern auch miteinander.
An Bord gibt es ein Kulturprogramm,
an dem schon mehr als
300 Künstler mitgewirkt haben.
Diesmal tritt die
Kontrabassistin Maike Hilbig auf,
die eine Lesung musikalisch untermalt.
Eine rollende Bibliothek bietet
den Reisenden viel Lesestoff
zur Vergangenheit
Deutschlands und Polens.
Und eine Dauerausstellung an den Sitzen
zeigt Lebenswege
deutscher und polnischer Breslauer.
Also, ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig,
dass es diese Verbindung jetzt durch
den Zug zwischen Wroclaw und Berlin gibt.
Dadurch gibt es [die] Möglichkeit,
sich kulturell auszutauschen,
und das ist ein sehr guter Weg,
die auch teilweise gemeinsame
Geschichte zu bearbeiten,
besser [zu] verstehen und auch
die Zukunft neu [zu] gestalten.
Das Konzept kommt an.
Viele hier sind auf Spurensuche.
Polen spielt schon ’ne gewisse Rolle
auch in unserer Familie.
Auch wenn wir jetzt keinen wirklich
richtigen biografischen Ursprung haben,
also schon viele Generationen
unser Name zurückliegt.
Aber zumindest habe ich ’ne
gewisse Nähe, ohne zu wissen,
wie die Nähe eigentlich aussieht.
Von daher bin ich ja interessiert.
Meine Großmutter ist in Schlesien geboren
an der polnisch-tschechischen Grenze
und hat dort die ersten zehn Jahre gelebt
und ist dann eben
nach Deutschland gekommen.
Und deswegen, weil ich, glaube [ich],
noch nie selber auch in Polen war,
war das auch ’n Grund für mich,
eben dorthin zu fahren und mal zu gucken.
Der Kulturzug wurde 2016
ins Leben gerufen,
als Breslau Europäische
Kulturhauptstadt war.
2017 bekam er einen Kulturmarken-Award
als „Trendmarke des Jahres“.
Autor Wolf Kampmann
hält hier oft Lesungen.
Dieser Zug ist ja nicht nur
ein Zubringer wie andere Züge.
Also, man setzt sich nicht nur rein,
um von einer Stadt
in die andere zu gelangen,
sondern um auf die Stadt
eingestimmt zu werden.
Ankunft in Breslau:
Überall in der Stadt findet man
Spuren der deutschen Vergangenheit.
Seit Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
ist Breslau ein Teil Polens.
Wolf Kampmann hat
einen Roman geschrieben,
der auf der Geschichte der Stadt basiert.
Bis 1945 war Breslau
eine nur deutsche Stadt.
Von 1946 bis in die 90er-Jahre
war es eine nur polnische Stadt gewesen.
Und es ist relativ neu,
dass erst in den letzten Jahren
ein Bewusstsein dafür entstanden ist,
dass es eine Stadt mit einer deutschen
und einer polnischen Geschichte ist
und man es jetzt als
deutsch-polnische Stadt
und auch als Begegnungsstätte
von Deutschen und Polen begreifen kann,
ohne dass immer gleich dieser
revanchistische Hintergedanke aufkommt.
Wolf Kampmann wird erst am nächsten Tag
mit dem Kulturzug nach Berlin zurückfahren.
Auf die Gäste, die sich jetzt schon
auf den Weg machen,
wartet an Bord eine „Silent Disco“.
Über Kopfhörer bekommen sie
die Musik direkt auf die Ohren.
Im Rhythmus vibrierende Gürtel
ersetzen den Bass.
Ich spüre für mich,
dass die Zukunft da ist.
Ich spüre, dass wir offen sind
und dass wir uns
in die richtige Richtung bewegen.
Und das macht mich glücklich.
Ja, wirklich.
Alle hier vereint zu sehen,
stimmt mich fröhlich.
Mehr als 30.000 Gäste
haben den Kulturzug schon genutzt.
Also, der Kulturzug
bringt tatsächlich Zug um Zug
die Leute näher zueinander –
ohne Komplikationen,
einfach auf ’ner sehr, sehr
lebendigen, spielerischen Ebene,
wo es einfach nicht darum geht,
dass man sich als Nation begegnet,
sondern als Menschen
auf der Basis der Kultur
und auf der Basis des Austauschs.
Die Organisatoren wollen das Projekt
auf zusätzliche europäische
Verbindungen ausweiten –
für mehr gegenseitiges Verständnis
und ein offeneres Europa.